now I do have to ask this is this film
will be Garry Shandling last film credit
you working with him on this and what
did that mean to you for this working
with him on this role well look I Gary's
you know got a huge place in my heart
not only was the in movies that I that I
directed but behind the scenes he's been
involved with both my movies and dozens
of other filmmakers if you look on
social media you'll see an outpouring of
affection because he would be behind so
many people creatively and give advice
and offer suggestions and just
encouragement extremely generous
generous generous man and very
bittersweet to be honest with you to
hear his voice in the film to see his
name and as I'm glad he's part of it but
also it's a I think it took everybody by
surprise who is a healthy great guy who
I don't think anybody thought we lose
them suit so soon and that's nice to
talk about them I think more people if
you don't know if you don't know about
Garry Shandling take a look at his work
it's it's stupendous
you